you're putting out a new album now right
now as you know as we speak is a new
album and now you're in the studio
describe to me last night you were in
the studio making another album
tonight
tonight
tonight
he's basically asleep like when did you
wake up yesterday to go to the studio i
woke up
at
2 30
in the afternoon 2 30 in the afternoon i
went and i kissed my baby girl
and then i went
uh and played some when baby girl that
you're referring to your girlfriend or
you have a baby
no that's my daughter oh you have a
daughter
yes sir that's been on the qt though we
didn't know you had a daughter right you
keep all that quiet
yeah i don't i i want to let her make
her own decisions that's it i admire
that and then we're off to where what
fun are we going to have we're going to
go right to the studio no sir we go we
play some apex legends we go look at
magic the gathering cards what is the
highest amount of money you ever paid
for a magic the gathering card eight
hundred thousand dollars unbelievable
look at you eight hundred thousand
dollars it was an artist print
chris rush signed black lotus i imagine
when you're playing apex legends
[ __ ] comes to you right like all of a
sudden you'll start hearing music in
your head
no [ __ ] literally comes to me because i
write all my songs on the can really
when you're [ __ ]
when you're
when you're [ __ ] it relaxes you
all right very much so yeah and you've
written what songs have you written
while shooting i'd say about
30 of all my albums have been written on
the [ __ ] and i'd say
i'd say i'd say
60 of lyrics have been written on the
[ __ ]
and when you say hey howard how how long
what's your what's your average [ __ ]
well i'm i've listened i learned my
lesson and you're going to learn you're
a young man i get off that pot in in
literally i [ __ ] and i'm off of there in
two minutes i've learned my lesson
you're going to get roids and you're
going to get all kind of but if you're
writing hit songs
on the can then just sit there let it
happen i'm like i'm like i'm like hour
and a half two hours oh come on but but
if you're [ __ ] what do you do do you
do you um take your iphone and start
singing into it so you don't forget
what's happening there on the on the can
no i just i have a notepad so it's not
the ipad or the iphone notes or the
itunes notes or whatever it is um i have
a special notepad off to the side where
i can work right now that you carry with
you no matter where you go a journal e
yes sir is it it's a and you take a pen
oh it's a digital journal
but you're not [ __ ] that whole time
but you're sitting there
are you pushing the whole time because
you really could get hemorrhoids and i'm
not making a joke uh it's my special
zone
okay it's okay it's my special zone
it's it's like
it's a cause no one wants to come talk
to you while you're taking a [ __ ]
right right
no one wants to come and talk to no one
i don't care who it is but does your
girlfriend ever say to you is she your
girlfriend or your wife at this point
this is my she's my fiance fiance okay
you're engaged does your fiance ever say
listen post i love you but for christ's
sake you're disappearing for two hours
in the can now you've got to get out and
you're going to get a mingle a little
bit is it it's it's too much of a
hideaway i wouldn't say it's a hideaway
as much as it's an oasis